Ajax stands for asynchronous JavaScript and
XML request, we can ignore the XML part of the acronym.
For now, let's just think of it as an asynchronous JavaScript request.
Ajax requests allow for content retrieval and
display without reloading the webpage.
Asynchronous in Ajax,
refers to the fact that the request doesn't block other events from happening.
Instead, the page keeps on doing its thing,
and then only acts on the data when it gets returned by the server.
AJAX requests occur in a number of different ways and
with varying levels of difficulty.
Some require an API key, others use O-off, and
some don't use any authentication at all.
And, the data returned by a different AJAX request differs too.
X in AJAX stands for XML which used to be the dominant hierarchical data format.
But today, JSON is much more popular,
in fact most AJAX requests nowadays are actually a JEDGE request standing for.
Asynchronous JavaScript and
Json request, but it doesn't sound as nice so we still just call them Ajax.
Embedded within Ajax responses, it's pretty common to see HTML,
which websites can use to fill in part part of page.
As part of the project for
this course, you'll have to try three different asynchronous request techniques.
You'll have to work with the Google Street View,
Wikipedia, and New York Times APIs, all three of which work very differently.